los aplausos de una victoria
con ansiedad y emoción unos 200
pasajeros salieron desde la estación
central de Ferrocarril de kiev con
destino hacia gerson luego de que fuera
anunciada la reapertura de la línea del
tren cerrada durante 8 meses por la
invasión a la ciudad de las tropas rusas
hasta la semana pasada cuando los
Soldados del kremlin anunciaron su
retiro de la zona
Anastasia estuvo atrapada en kiev desde
marzo finalmente logró viajar a su
ciudad natal para reencontrarse con su
madre compré los llamados boletos para
la victoria pero no esperaba que se
convirtiera en realidad Cuando
estuvieron disponibles inmediatamente
Compré uno y Ayer me llamaron diciendo
que el tren estaba a punto de dirigirse
a gerson el tren viajó unos 450
kilómetros desde la capital hasta la
ciudad más importante que Rusia logró
invadir el recorrido duró unas 11 horas
y media y el dinero de los boletos
recaudado será destinado a apoyar el
ejército ucraniano de momento solo
viajará a un tren diario pero se espera
que la frecuencia aumente ya ejerzo en
muchos llegaron a la estación para
celebrar mientras otros esperaban el
anhelado reencuentro con sus seres
queridos
Esta es mi madre ella también está feliz
me espero todo este tiempo sobrevivió a
la ocupación aquí
Le prometí que volvería sucedió Así que
mantuve Mi promesa en el centro de la
ciudad los cafés las estaciones de
gasolina y los comercios están
reabriendo sus puertas mientras buscan
recuperarse de los estragos de la
invasión rusa
en este momento algo tan sencillo como
un café eleva mi ánimo entre un 200 y
300%.
de igual manera cientos de residentes se
reunieron en la plaza principal de
gerson para recoger paquetes con comida
y ropa preparándose para el invierno que
ya registra temperaturas bajo cero en
todo el país